so here he is doing a round table for
the folks for the quote-unquote
journalists at Time Magazine and listen
to the way he frames what's going on in
society today you'll see how this is
connected to the trance though
I think it's safe
especially right now when you have one
side that has a maximalist commitment to
tearing down every Norm uh and uh and
law they don't like
so where does that put us and by the way
why does it happen
I think it's happening because there are
some people who find it easier
to
pick on really vulnerable young people
then to explain why they voted no on
money for roads and bridges
it's like the perfect
ridiculous shell game answer that
Democrats do with everything first off
this line one side has a maximalist
commitment to tearing down everything uh
you mean like tearing down gender like
tearing down our border like tearing
down every known way we've looked at
monetary policy forever
etc etc are you talking about the
Democrats I think if you are talking
about the Democrats you might be on to
something but of course Pete's not
talking about the Democrats he's trying
to pretend that the Republicans are
passing scary bills to come after trans
people and might I remind you there is
not one bill in the United States in any
state that stops an adult trans person
from living any way that they wish to
live wearing whatever they want being
called whatever they want calling
themselves whatever they want getting
into whatever relationship they might
want to get into that any other
consenting adult is allowed to get into
but he says these things and then he
sits around a group of what I assume are
DC or New York you know liberal lefties
who just sit there and oh my God look at
Pete he can put a couple words together
isn't he good isn't he good
foreign
[Music]